this is chess brand Master Yasser
sarawan bringing you broadcast coverage
of the 37th chess Olympiad this is your
first uh Olympiad Magnus how is your
individual result uh well it's not my
first Olympian actually okay well there
you go sorry well I I also played in
2004 also first
what so you were 13 then when you played
the first board for the for Norway yeah
well I had two wins three draws and I
know that one of your wins was against
Michael Adams one of the players in the
top six in the world and certainly from
San Luis he was a participant yeah it
was great to win against him yeah I
think he's the highest rated player I
have ever been in normal chest oh
wonderfully it just seems to me that
you're going from success to success